[Music]
the war here in ukraine has lasted more
than four months but back in february on
its first day karolina perlafon came
face to face with death
that's when russian soldiers on a
roadway in eastern ukraine opened fire
on the car she was in with her mother
irina
her 51 year old mother was wounded hit
by a bullet in the head she died there
on the spot carolina was her only child
which was
in those minutes carolina thought she
was dead too recording and later posting
this video to instagram thanking her
parents for giving her life you hear the
gunfire in the background
but carolina survived the roadside
attack partly because two russian
soldiers including this man refused to
carry out their orders to kill
ukrainians there on the spot
[Music]
the lieutenant colonel gave the order to
shoot civilians this soldier told
ukrainian interrogators after his
capture authorities shared the video
with carolina
she's still processing what happened
that day those soldiers could have
killed you
at that time couldn't they mug
instead the young soldiers were soon hit
by gunfire one died and this soldier was
injured he was bleeding and couldn't
walk
then perhaps an even more remarkable act
than the soldier's decision not to kill
as her mother lay dead from a russian
bullet carolina drove the young russian
soldier to safety why did you do that
taking the soldier 10 minutes away to
get medical attention she realized he
survived when she saw the interrogation
video
he would have died she told us i
wouldn't have been able to live and i
know i had a chance to save him he's a
human he didn't do anything to me the 29
year old lawyer who lost her mother to
russians who targeted civilians still
coping with her loss and confident she
did what was right
shauna shea global news near kharkiv
ukraine